Hi, I'm Marya Choby and I'm a dating coach.
I'm sharing dating strategies for shy and introverted singles.
Right now, I'm going to talk about how to meet people to date.
The number one way to meet new people is to be introduced by friends.
But if you want to get set up,...
...you have to let your friends know you're interested and available to be set up.
Make friends with people of all genders and all ages.
You'll get comfortable in the environment...
...and have friendly, supportive people around you.
Build communities around your passions and interests.
Attend lectures, take classes and participate in individual sports...
...like biking or hiking with the group.
Consider online dating.
Don't be afraid to convey your richness and depth in your profile.
Give yourself the opportunity to talk on the phone a few times before meeting...
...to increase your comfort level.
So, what about parties and bars?
Learn to spot other introverts to chat with.
They'll be relieved you're talking with them...
...and happy to be exempt from working the room.
Also, try to find yourself a chair.
You'll feel safer and more grounded if you can sit down.
If you run into someone worth meeting, it's great if you can get introduced.
If not, consider taking the initiative.
Being an introvert doesn't mean you can't be assertive.
You'll just want to break the interaction into small chunks.
Make eye contact and smile when you're one-on-one at the food table or bar.
A little later, say hello again and smile.
You'll feel like old friends by the end of the night.
So, those are some strategies for meeting people to date.